hey everybody
awesome news they just dropped the Robin
costume on us from the Titan series so
obviously you know that we're doing Dick
Grayson Titans but we're gonna see a
couple different versions of the
character throughout the series we
finally have the finished version of his
first costume so there are a couple
things to explain here like what we're
actually looking at whether this is
gonna be in present day or whether we're
gonna see flashbacks to his time as
Robin but if you're just finding me for
the first time we do DC every week be
sure to subscribe to get everything
they'll even be new giveaway stuff at
the end of the video but let's freak out
about the costume for a second so if
you're not really familiar with Robin
from the comics there's been a bunch of
different versions of the Dick Grayson
costume so like every era that comes
along they redesigned the costume a
little bit so Nightwing in present-day
when he's remembering things when he was
a kid and he was running around with
Batman as Robin or when Damian Wayne is
trying to make fun of him telling him
that his Robin costume looks super lame
they redesigned it just a little bit so
what this looks like is a modernized
version of the new 52 original Dick
Grayson costume he's using the signature
staff but you'll also know that he uses
Escrima sticks when he becomes Nightwing
so what they might wind up doing is just
giving us everything from the character
so remember daredevil season 1 he didn't
get his bolo stick until later in the
series he didn't even get his daredevil
costume till the very end
but we know based on the pitch of the
series and the characters they're doing
the place that it's set that they're
gonna be doing a lot of Chuck Dixon era
Nightwing when he was a police officer
he became a detective and it would run
around during the day just solving
crimes then do all the vigilante
Nightwing stuff at night that he
couldn't do during the day as a cop so
it makes sense but this series is all
about the Titans coming together for the
first time so it sounds like he's left
Batman gone out on his own but he still
hasn't taken the Nightwing persona and
he's gone back to blüdhaven his home
town and he's going to be a police
officer to try and help people just to
try and figure out what life is like
when he's not with the Batman they've
done that a couple different times in
the comics they just did it in the
rebirth comics where he's like I'm gonna
go out on my own I just need to do
something by myself
for a little while I've been running
around with Batman for so long I don't
know what it is that I want to do with
the rest of my life or how I want to be
a superhero because he has very
different ideas than the Batman he's
sort of like the Joker funnier version
of the Batman that's able to smile more
often which is why he would make a great
Batman someday because he already has
all the skills he needs he just doesn't
have the city miles on him that Bruce
Wayne does there's just certain things
about being the Batman that you can only
learn through experience and he's just
so much younger that it's just gonna
take him a while to get there so that's
the whole idea is that he'll eventually
take the mantle from Bruce Wayne and
then someday Damian Wayne will take the
mantle from Dick Grayson but as far as I
know the Titans TV series is only doing
Dick Grayson and we don't know what
Batman's status is during the course of
the series if he's taken on Jason Todd
if he's been through that saga like if
it's just an in-between period so they
could play with the timeline just a
little bit but the whole idea here like
they just mentioned Batman on arrow this
series immediately canonized as Batman
in the universe because you can't do
Robin without Batman so it'll be
interesting to see how they dance around
Bruce Wayne in the series I have an idea
for how he's going to work out in the
aro universe but he's a little bit
further off there there's still a lot of
questions about how this series is
related to arrow just remember so
there's actually a really cool thing
that was revealed on Kevin Smith's
podcast a little while ago I'll play the
clip in a second but the Berlanti people
are working behind the scenes on the
show but not necessarily the same exact
people that write the flash arrow
Supergirl legends of tomorrow Titans is
being shot in Toronto all of DC TV is
being shot in Vancouver so it's like a
completely different part of the country
and they even have the black lightning
TV show that they're working on
separately that's being shot in Atlanta
there's a guy who does effects for flash
and Supergirl Arman Arman Kevorkian and
he's working on he's working on the Teen
Titans show and he sent me a text this
week on you were gonna [ __ ] love the
Robin outfit yeah it looks cool he says
I'm looking forward to that Teen Titans
show but now I'm looking way forward to
this Harley Quinn
that's a good idea [ __ ] that took a long
time so they're all over the place with
this stuff so when people asked about
black lightning being connected to the
arrowverse they're like we're gonna do
season one then maybe we'll work on
crossing them over I think it's gonna be
the same approach with Titans like
they're gonna do it as their own thing
in worst case scenario they just say
that it's on a different earth in the
multiverse so we think the Supergirl is
probably the best example of that like
she is directly connected to the other
shows but yet they keep her on an
alternate earth so that they just don't
have to worry about Superman and all
that stuff being on arrow in the flash
but they just confirmed that there is a
Bruce Wayne on earth one this is
important I am NOT the green arrow
number two photos can be doctored they
could have put Bruce Wayne's head on
that body as Bruce Wayne left Gotham to
hang out in Star City recently no so you
can get as complicated as you want to
with this but just let me know what do
you think of the Robin costume I think
it actually looks pretty badass it looks
better than most of the arrowverse
costumes the flash was the last person
to get a big costume upgrade at the
beginning of the season so obviously now
that we've seen the Robin costume what
we'll probably see is the costumes from
Starfire Raven and Beast Boy and then
obviously there's a whole bunch of other
supporting characters like Hawk and Dove
we might wind up seeing their costumes
and then if you haven't seen it I've
done a separate video about the cast
that they're including from the Teen
Titans comic books like they're doing
brother blood they're doing some of
ravens family because of all the Trigon
stuff those characters will probably
just dress like normal people like the
comic book costumes will be most of the
vigilantes
maybe brother blood will have a
crazy-looking costume but I'm assuming
because they want to hype up the core
Titans roster what they'll do is they
might reveal Ravens costume next then
Starfire then maybe Beast Boy Starfire
they might try and tiptoe around a
little bit because any redesign to a
classic costume can be controversial and
it's not like they're gonna make the
actress walk around in a swimsuit every
single day so I'm just expecting a
slightly different twist on Starfire's
comic book costume but if you've seen
arrow you know the different versions of
The Black Canary costume that you've
seen from the comics so in the way that
they changed that a little bit they're
probably going to tweak Starfire's
costume rave
is probably the easiest one to do like
you put a gem in her forehead and then
just have her wear a big long cape
that's about it everybody else is just a
little bit trickier but they have been
shooting the first couple of episodes
hopefully they have enough footage for a
trailer to release or a teaser before
the end of the year but no confirmation
on that this is just a prelude to them
dropping footage like hey this is first
little look here we're gonna give you a
picture then in the not-too-distant
future we're gonna give you a little bit
of footage but just remember if you're
excited about robbing right now just
looking at this then think about what
it's gonna look like when we roll into a
new season and they reveal the Nightwing
costume but leave all your Titans
Nightwing bonus video requests in the
comments below
there'll be an agents of shield episode
one Easter Egg video posting tomorrow
but there is a new round of that flash
ring giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber leave a comment
on this video congratulations to the
winner from my last video Aaron please
private message me so I can get your
contact details click here for the brand
new flash mid season finale trailer and
click here to rewatch that Infinity Ward
trailer
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight